今天的語言模式在模擬語言上成功,沒有驚訝。
他們很擅長在討論、寫文、翻譯、
在介紹你介紹的文章中修復錯誤,
你需要發訊息和分享這些東西。
然而,我們越來越使用同樣的模式來解決問題。
例如,數學、寫文、正式思維和其他各種東西。
所以, 互動是語言, 要求是數學。
所以, 我會花很多時間問這個討論, 什麼可以讓語言模式能夠實際地數學。
這是第九集,題目是《語言模型的兩種看法》。
講話的人叫Ryan Cotterell,蘇黎世聯邦理工學院的教授,
專門拿形式語言理論去量神經網絡的能耐。
這場會引用到的定理,有好幾個是他跟學生掙出來的,最新的一個今年才發表。
他自己說,整個工作坊裡做這一行的大概只有他一個
在這個討論中,
我將談論數據,
而不是理論,
雖然理論在社區中更加流行,
人們討論理論,
我認為數據是一個比較適合的語言,
為什麼我認為這些語言超過了這個討論的目標,
但我願意在休息中給您解釋,
所以我將談論數據。
所以,我將談論數據。
首先,我將開始談論 probabilistic distribution view
然後,最多的談論將是談論數學模式的模式
這是我們認為的語言模式在談論數學模式的設定
好,我們現在將進入數學模式的設定
在談論中,很少人會提出數學模式的數學定義
我開始做這個,我先做一些基本的語言理論語言語言
我們有一個文字,通常是Sigma,是一個無空的細節細節
一個細節是一個細節細節從Sigma取得的細節
我們很關注在電腦科學上的清潔和關聯
這是所有細節的細節,我們用了Sigma為空的細節
這是細節的細節的細節
這與sigma和同等性相同,
sigma star也是免費的免費物質,
這是從數學觀點來看。
以少數的數字為例,
我會使用這個小組合,
在這裡,這個t-t是第一個1-t-1的參數
這是一個基本的數學理論文化語言語言語言
我們在語言語言語言上研究的經典項目是認識者
認識者是一種語言的特殊功能
語言是一種星星的組成
我們有一個碼,從星星到零零
我們可以談談語言的複雜性,
無論是否無法決定的語言,
無論是否正常的語言。
語言模式,
這就是歷史的定義,
雖然它在許多現代文章中被複雜,
一種比較普遍的數據,我們會看看為什麼,是比較比較的缺陷幾率。
我把這個在P上面的小鑰匙上定義了,從左到右。
這基本上就是一條缺陷幾率的幾率,如果你選擇了一條缺陷幾率,
這就是一條缺陷幾率的幾率,它開始在x裡面,
然後你就可以解決整體的繼續性。
有時候你能夠把這個變成一種計算法,有時候你不可以。
還有,我們經常在談論缺陷幾率的缺陷幾率。
那麼我們是如何管理的呢?
以我們看到了這個旋律的項目的x,
那麼我們繼續用y作為可能性嗎?
好的,所以這是在計算一些基本的數據。
這個數量在這些文章中,
不太好,也不太常在這些文章中說明。
好的,所以現在我們要進入一個
我稱為自動逐漸的幾率的幾率,
這比較像在一本訓練工程中
你可能看到的東西。
所以我們介紹了一個新的參數,
EOS的端端,
主要不在Sigma,
而我們定義EOS的可能性
以x為這個比率,
以x為這個標準的可能性,
而我們可以
根據任何的
端端的分配,
以每個端端的可能性
來計算,然後停止。
而這個原因是,
我們有一個等級,
端端是一個等級的,
所以我們必須要考慮這些
實際上這個n在這裡會是一個 random variable
我們正在詳細解釋
好,所以這是一篇文章
因為我聽到很多人會說的東西
通常是像一種語言模式
只是下一個參數預測器
對於我來說,這不是定義
定義是這個分辨數
我們可以總是用一種語言模式
以這種方式分辨
所以那是一種理論,不是定義
還有其他定義
我們可能會擔心其他定義
例如,如果我們要從左到右走
我們可以從右到右走
或是從左到右走,或是從左到右走
所以這裡有個有趣的問題
是一位同學問過的
就是
你能否定義一種語言模式
你總是可以的
而是你需要花多少錢
在定義範圍上
例如詳細性
你能夠這樣做嗎
你能夠這樣定義嗎
剛才在這篇文章中提到的一部分,
原因是因為是一個語言模式來定義語言模式,
因為許多語言模式的語言模式並不是語言模式。
例如,你能想象一下,
你只需要翻轉一個加密貨幣的語言模式,
它是無論是頭還是尾的,
然後,這種數據實際上將幾乎沒有幾乎幾乎的幾乎的幾乎的幾乎,
而所有的幾乎都在幾乎幾乎的幾乎中。
所以,這是為什麼我真的喜歡這個調整較成雷的定義,
我們將看到它和這種認為數據的計算的概念的相互合作。
好,現在我們來談談組織一個語言模式來分析。
所以,這是一個我將在課程結束後再進行的例子,
希望我們能到達這裡。
但是,這是一個非常有用的思想測試。
why sorting?
why sorting
它是一種科學科學家學的第一種 alg
他們學習了泡泡分辨
他們學習了分辨
it's definitely doing computation
這是比較複雜的問題,比較困難的問題。
ok so to set up the notation
我會假設我擁有sigma,
也就是k分別的參數,
我會假設在那些k分別的參數中,
有一個總數,
So I'm going to train language models,
我可以用一個語言模式來專輯一個綜合的語言
是一個缺乏的缺乏的缺乏的缺乏
And then I'm going to fill out the...
I'm going to have the separator symbol
然後我會訓練語言模式來適應這種分辨
So this is very, very simple.
So the question you might ask is like,
假設我訓練語言模式來適應這種分辨
這就是目標分辨
這是語言的定義,所以它是一個顯示功能
最基礎的問題是
P是什麼時候
when is it a good model of P star?
這裡有兩種可能的答案
你可以考慮一下例如總的變異距離
P和P'的距離
也可以談談預期的縮解準確率
有點點的數學會顯示
這些是總的變異距離
縮解準確率預期的縮解準確率
你可以使用Pinkster的縮解準確率
把KL帶進圖片裡
但是我們有預期的縮解準確率
是關於模擬適合真正的分辨
所以你可以說,
如果我們適用了P,
我們可以說P,
我們的語言模式學習了調整嗎?
我說的答案是不。
原因是因為當我們談論algorithm時,至少在學術學院學習時,這並不是我們所意味著的。
我們不意味著它只是用一個高 probabilistic set of inputs。
好,所以這將帶來的設定是
語言模式的看法
在統計的設定中的設定
所以它必須在所有的設定中工作
不只是高 probabilistic 設定
how well does this model predict
what's good average case prediction
我們關心普通的高可能性輸出
分析的觀點是,這個模式怎麼分析和如何分析呢?
這要求正確的選擇選擇。
我說正確的意味著,當你是一名數學學生時,
你進行了你的第一個選擇課程,
你發現了正確的證據,
這就是我說的正確的意味。
因此,分析的觀點經常有很少說明
關於簡單或不正確的分析。
現在,我們來談談這個
第二個觀點的語言模式作為一個分析。
我們如何從一個分辨率計算到一個計算模式
是否有答案
因為我們想從我之前說的那種計算模式
去認識它
我們想要一個計算模式
所以,有些人可能會說
我們可能只是規律上限它
但是這很壞
因為這種計算模式
在我們語言中只能有一個
有線的細小數字
所以這種計算模式是很嚴重的
我們在這種計算模式中
例如,你可以用到
自動反應認識
你需要每個綜合的項目
這會做到無限語言
你可以說,如果有一個提示,那是什麼 argmax
So these two are workable
the finicky details.
The finicky details
That is to say once we fix a manner
然後我們將談論繪圖的進行,
那麼有很多問題會自然發生。
所以第一個問題是
語言模式有多明顯
我意思是
我們可以想象一下
我們能夠把語言模式放在
傳統傳統上
第二個問題
我開始很關心的
就是準確性
就是說
傳統傳統中
因為它們非常低於喬姆斯基 hierarchy
它們是不正常的
所以這些是非常不明顯的模式
然而 準確性是
我們如何能夠準確這些模式
所以這意味著
我們有這些非常不明顯的模式
通常是非常非常準確的
這意味著我們學習了這個東西
像是一個非常非常非常大的
細膩的產物
除了它不是任何一種
它是一個非常細膩的細膩產物
但是它是一個非常非常大的
非常不明顯的產物
第三個問題是更具有關系的問題
就是如何去分析這些語言模式的正確工具
我們需要如何去思考他們
我們可能需要邏輯、數學、或是路線的複雜性
好,我們在我們在這些很好的問題中開始前
我們要討論一個更根本的問題
就是我們想研究的正宗物體是什麼
而這點是因為
是說,一種真正的轉換器是一個非常混亂的工具
有豐富的 precision 和豐富的粗糙,也有學習的重量
也有設計選擇的設計,一樣一樣的
我們經常需要定義,給一個數學定義
一個這樣的轉換器的定義
首先,我想先說明一下
我們需要一個數學定義的轉換器
來開始這種過程
我現在要給一個例子
所以,假設你有這個algorithm在這裡。
也許有些人認識這個algorithm。
如果你不認識,沒關係。
假設你被這個algorithm給了這個algorithm。
你會問,這個algorithm是怎麼做的?
我們如何預測這個algorithm?
它是嚴格的。
所以,這就是Euler的方法,
就是將解決方法的解決方法,
與這個分辨式的解決方法相似。
但是,這個不同的是,
分辨式的解決方法首先出現了。
也就是說,我們以這個algorithm
作為一個來從這種傳統理想的理想
這種下述的數學理論
And that way, we don't, we can talk,
我們可以進行數學分析
和解決這個理論
因為這意味著
或是有浮動點的程式
都是我們很開心的不必要處理的不正確的
我們很開心如果我們只有一種
好的分辨式解決方法
好的
相反
轉換器給我們一個相反的情況
它給我們一個有效的工具
並不是一個存在前的物體的無視
一個隱瞞的地方是
But that's sort of like a mechanism
這不是真正的真相
And moreover
This means that
我稍後再解釋一下
Finite precision is not obviously
An approximation error in a transformer
So the first thing we sort of have to do
重新設計這個錯誤的物體
以作為我們可以理解的
That we can sort of reason about
這裡我們跳過三分鐘
他把transformer的正式定義走了一遍
只要記得一步
Attention先替每個位置打分數
再用Softmax把分數變成全重
他接下來動的就是這一步
所以在分析上,你可以得到不同的結果,
就在你願意與它們合作的程度上.
所以,一個常用的選擇是,
或者兩個常用的選擇,
就是用純粹的分析,
和Turing的完整性的結果
但問題是這些並不代表
我們認為轉換器能做到的東西
所以這並不是幫助我們的理論
所以這是一個非常重要的選擇
而在關於耐熱的關係上
我們經常將Softmax
變成一個減少溫度的限制
這實際上是為了
研究方便而做到的
用這個方法更容易證明理論
即使你把整個建築
都保留在一樣
所以我們將談論的結果
是耐熱轉換器
但至某程度上
它們可以被平均化
OK,
so as I said,
this precision thing,
如果您想要,我希望您可以帶來這段談話
就是精準是重要的
this is a great paper,
這是一個很好的文章
or from the RNN case,
an older Siegelman and Sontag paper,
but these proofs,
if you go through them,
如果您通過它們
而是你能夠使用一個無法定義的長線
一個定義的線,能夠使用一個線圖形式
不必學習這些
無論轉換器,沒有任何方式
只要用一個計算價
就可以用這個計算價
來標記一個轉換器的圖案
如果你讀過這些證據
你不會覺得你解釋了很多
所以我們會限制準確
因為它避免這些
不太好用的複雜結果
但無論如何
這就會讓我們有一個
想要的模型的問題
好,我說了,硬重力
這是一個不同的原因
這允許解決分析
雖然我們會談談
有些理論比較軟
但是當我們談談心臟
我們就開始證明理論
那些理論很容易被證明
而我們喜歡這些理論
但我們不認為這些理論是不合理的原因
是因為有些理論
與非常好建立的
複雜數據相關
所以在許多情況下
這些理論的解決
尤其是在一些這些
這些理論解決了一些經典的數學理論
好,我們來談談這三個理論解決方案
首先,我們來談談這些
這些叫做SMATS
在文化中,這叫做Softmax Attention Transformer
這並不是一個理論解決方案
它只是原來的方法
我們有U-HATS
U-HATS是你將單純的ArgMax
我會談談鞋子的解決方法
我們解決鞋子的解決方法
還有A鞋子
A鞋子的解決方法是
你選擇低溫限度
和最高位置的平衡
這三種解決方法
對
U鞋子的解決方法是
鞋子的解決方法是
當你的ARGMAC有
更多的一個元素
你選擇解決鞋子的解決方法
可以改變結果
所有結果都挺有趣的
它們是很自然的
但是有趣的是,這一小小的細節改變了分析。
所以我想談談專業語言的專業語言。
我特別想談談,我們來談談 Star Free 語言,
這些語言並非中學課程的語言,所以它們有點奇怪。
所以許多數學家,甚至許多數學家,
他們學習了 Chomsky  hierarchy,
所以我們可以分辨,如我所說的,我們有這種認識,
我們可以分辨語言的複雜性,
因為我們有不同的設備,經常會有增加的複雜性,
而這些設備是接受的。
例如,一種普通的語言,例如A-star,B-star,或是傳統語言,
例如Mod-2,這些是不普通的語言,
所以一種普通的語言是不普通的語言。
例如平衡的語言,例如Python,這些是不普通的語言。
你能夠得到正確的選擇
然後你能夠得到一個
與圖形機構成相同的語言
所以這是傳統的
傳統的傳統圖形機構
而最大的結果是
固定的 precision transformers
基本上是一種 sub-regular
那就是他們接受了
傳統語言的語言
低於普通語言
這很難以期待
因為我們想起
這些大力的語言模式
我們可能會期待它們
像圖形機構
但它們不是
我們明白的那樣
它們非常弱
So a sub-regular language is in a sense
是正常語言中存在的語言
所以我們今天要談論的東西
我會給它們幾個特徵
I might skip a few for time
But the sort of high-level point of view
就是一件不能做的事
就是它不能算Mod2
So this is sort of
米歇爾·漢在2020年發表了一篇文章
and he sort of showed that a transformer
他展示了一種
我們現在不是在討論
so that can augment things a bit,
but basic transformer can't count mod 2,
so that's kind of a problem,
所以這就是一個問題
So,
所以,
它是一種有很多相同的特色
many equivalent characterizations,
which is why people like them,
讓我們覺得我們是一個自然的類別
如果您想想詳細的定律定律定律的定律定律
您知道它有定律狀態和一個轉換方式
這個定律定律除了普通語言
這個語言是雷射無限的
當定律定律是非定律的
那就是
沒有任何的非定律
轉換方式
是一筆語言
沒有任何的非定律
所以這就是你會得到的
例如估計MOD2
是不可分辨的
另一個原因
另一個方法討論它們
就是我們有普遍的表現
這就像Cleanies的普遍語言
我們經常與它們互動
這是普遍表現的
我們可以討論
我們有三個行動
Union, Concatenation, and Cleanies Star
我們可以討論普遍表現的
普遍表現不分辨的
我們放下了 star
這就是它的名字
來源,然後我們添加順序,所以這是這堂語的另一個特徵。
所以你,你可以得到,Sigma,所有的Sigma明星是明星,
因為它是空間的順序,但是,
但是,是的,有些東西,例如傳統是沒有的。
有幾個邏輯特徵,如果你有一個邏輯超過第一組,
對不起,純粹的組織,明星無線語言就是
第一組邏輯的邏輯。
而還有另一種邏輯,在電子科學上很受歡迎,
在電子科學上很受歡迎的,
那就是我所謂的世界線組織,
我們有這些不同的選擇。
And with this,
it's less expressive,
而有很多不同的相同的語言
which is why this is not very obscure,
And this is a class that transformers,
至少某種類型的轉換模式都被聯繫了
好的,所以為瞭解釋為何轉換模式被聯繫
或是為瞭解釋為何你可能在後期期待
會有關於星座自由語言和轉換模式之間的關係
是因為過去的運作者在鋰定軌道理論上
基本上,如果你想像是從左到右的輪圈讀取
它在說,如果我進行過程後,是否有任何疑惑在我背後
這就是證據的道理
第一個結果是關於U-hat
我再給大家展示一下我的定義
當我們擁有一個獨特的耳朵
我們選擇一個
我們得到的定義
這是丹娜·安格蘭 安迪·楊和David Chang的
U-hat轉換器認識語言
只要它是無星化的
而在這個版本上,我們不需要詳細的預測
但是我為了在2024年發生這種驚人的結果
我為了把這種充滿識別語言的充滿語言的充滿
你能夠重新重新重新回應
對這個很明確的類型的練習語言的關係
這很有趣
誰會認為這樣的
非常驚訝
好
讓我給大家一個理解
因為 recurrent neural networks
我說的就是它們是一般的
有確定的證明
但是它們僅僅是在這種
的嚴格的精切評價上
但如果你有的深度精切的NN
它們非常容易顯示
它們正確認識正確的正常語言
這是實際上顯示的
所以為什麼這是有趣的
對不起,所以正常語言是
正常語言有豐富的精確性
它們與正常語言有豐富的聯繫
這是Marvin Minsky所顯示的
50年代的不同版本的正常語言
而這裡有趣的是
是川普是網絡共同宣傳中的
而是在網絡共同宣傳中的
主要的解釋是
為什麼我們的模型變弱了
這是一種反應
它被迫害的
只是一個解釋
但是 我們還要給你
一個有趣的解釋
好
所以
我們也可以用得上一種更比較精明的圖案
就是說
如果我們來玩的
有時候人們在玩的
不同的免動的情形
你甚至可以獲得 Star Free 語言的 sub-classes
在我學生焦德的近期報告中
我們可以顯示不同種類的 attention maps
關鍵線在星座自由語言的不同 subclasses 上
另一個結果,這是 Softmax attention transformers
如果你有 finite precision
也就是我們掌握了 finite precision
你會得到的,它們是 R-trivial 語言
這是星座的另一個組織
和LTL的P類似
這些是有趣的建議
但是你必須要計算一下
所有浮浪點的數字
但無論如何
它們是有用的定義
如果我們有softmax
我們就能解決了
好
我會舉個簡單的
circuit complexity的順序
以示出A hat的結果
有一個最近的文章,
我喜歡的,
是Kuladas和Sengupta的,
他們的解釋是,
為什麼玻璃線路線應該是正確的鏡頭對於傳輸者來說。
在許多方面,這種解釋是傳輸者的原則。
我將在一分鐘內解釋到這方面的關於無線語言。
但有趣的是,這是一個小史課。
玻璃線路線非常受歡迎,尤其是在80年代,因為他們很擅長描述相同的數據。
它們是一種比較明確的複雜計劃
所以它是自然的
因為轉換器被選擇了
為了能夠被連接
所以這個工具
非常有用
在連接計劃中
是一個很棒的工具
好的
所以我想給大家
一個簡單的概念
不同類型的線路
因為有一個東西
線路的複雜計劃
是類似數碼的情況
有兩個類型的線路
我們要關心的
一個叫AC0
另一個叫TC0
AC0就是你可能認為是一個運行軟件
你會有不運行軟件,各有不運行軟件
你會有運行軟件的長度
我再說一下運行軟件的家庭
TC0是AC0加上主要運行軟件
也就是它可以計算
80年代非常經典的結果是
AC0是TC0的固定運行軟件
Module 2 is not in AC0.
記得我們談論了
Module 2.
We'll get back to that.
我們再回顧一下
Because circuits, we can extend them
to be take as input strings.
但線路用來輸出一個固定的輸出
例如一個N尺寸的固定輸出
所以要認識一個語言
one for each length.
這是我想要強調的一種
因為我們有這一系列的物體
在不同的長度上的運行中
我們必須要考慮如何組織它們
所以我們必須要有一個設備
可以把每個長度的線條拆除
否則如果我們不小心
我們可以組織一個線條
用一個無法決定的語言
所以我意思是
如果你有一個無線條的線條
你基本上可以有一個
每個長度的適當線條
你可以用這種方式設定很多
但我們通常會說
就是說,你有一種轉向機器,
每個長度的線路都被刪除了,
我們有一個線路,
能在那種轉向機器上運行多久。
所以,當我們說什麼,
像是,Dlog Time Uniform,
我們意思是,
一個轉向機器,
一個定位性轉向機器,
在 logarithmic time中,
會出現N的轉向線路。
所以,N是logic time。
好的,
所以,我說,
以這兩個觀點合作,
star-free的語言
正是AC0的正常語言。
就是AC0
所以這是它們開始結合的地方
好的
所以我給了這些簡單的語言
來談談AHAD的結果
平均硬接觸
還有SMAT
所以與Log Precision
SMAT和平均硬接觸
基本上可以認識很多東西
在TC0裡面
不是所有東西
它們是TC0的高線
是由David Chang幫忙製作的
這意味著
它是高級的
所以任何不夠TC0的東西
Transformer就不可以做
你可以傳輸一下
像我的學生一樣
我們可以傳輸一下
用不同的平衡性
去得到所有TC0的東西
但是我們需要一些插件
和一些深度
如果你知道Transformer的文章
我們需要一些傳輸
你一開始談論增長的準確性
好的,
然後我們將進入一些
所以細節性基本上是一種
我們可以說,如果一種方法比其他比較細膩,
如果你可以找到一種語言的家庭,
對不起,一種語言家庭,
第一個需要比較細膩的,
第一個需要像n個子,
第二個需要2個n個子。
這裡有一個很詳細的例子,
可能很多人都看到,
就是分別是決定性和非決定性的
細膩自動動力。
決定性可能會把機器撐起來,
而不是其他方式,
你可以顯示這是細膩的。
可以在某些情況下減弱機器
所以我們可以展示的是
這些UHAT轉換器
它們能夠實際地
認識星座無線語言
但它們也能認識
DFA會需要
2到2到的n的語言
來認識
所以這是一種
開始的解釋
因為更有趣的是
相比於RNN
它們能夠逐漸地
更加的細膩
所以在這個角度
轉換器可以認識
是一個非常非常非常非常非常大的RNN
它不能表達所有能表達的RNN
但在它們分享的類型中
它可以變得非常非常非常複雜
這解釋出
可能這就是為什麼我們喜歡Transformers
對於AHATS來說
這大多數是開放的
這個結果是我們今年公佈的
對於UHATS來說
我不太認識AHATS
以及它們的複雜性
這還是複雜的
然後這是什麼意思的
為瞭解釋能力
而如果您接受UHAT模式
實際上,解釋能力
是x space hard
對不起,是x space complete
所以這比NP hard更難
所以我們不會找到
一個有效的方法
來解釋能力
如果我們用這些理論
好,回過頭來
再回顧一下,我最喜歡的一部分是它很難解釋我們所觀察到的一些理想結果,
這就是為何轉換器可能會更優秀於模擬RNN,即使RNN是更明顯的,
而對我們來說,理想結果可能是更明顯的答案,
而我們仍然看待理想結果比較理想,有更多的控制。
好的,我將在語言上結束,
因為有很多更厲害的技術結果,
我們將將這些語言語言語言進入,
因為我覺得有趣,
人們有意見,
所以,
這些語言語言語言的語言語言是
最有名的一個東西,
所以,
他會說,
你說什麼,
我認為許多英語語言人都會同意,
貓坐在地板上,是一個文字,
地板,是一個貓坐在地板上,不是文字。
And Chomsky really cared about this,
even for nonsensical sentences,
sort of his famous example,
colourless green ideas sleep furiously.
他說,即使這並沒有意義,
it's grammatical
colourless is not.
So in 57, he was already arguing,
and he gets caught out for this,
他認為一句話的可能性是不可分別的
因為他無法分辨A和B
因為他認為兩者的可能性是零
但是英語的語言
如果你說英語
你會有證據
所以他在50年代的記錄中
說不要用語言模式
更詳細的說
這不是我所在意的問題
但無論如何
我們會看到為什麼它是有可能性的
所以在65年代
在他著名的書中
《語言理論的部分》
他基本上談到
另一個區別
我認為會有很大影響
計算機的解釋力
那就是能力和能力
所以 argument was if you have the rat the cat ate died
we can all understand that
but if we keep centering betting
雞吃虎,狗吃狗,死亡,死亡
it's very hard to say very hard to parse
當我們在對方對方當中創造了詞彙
他對此的論點是
但人類的原因是
我們只是在我們自己的智慧網絡上運用英文
這並不是一個很好的模式
並不是一個很好的軟件
所以這個進步的程度
在某些角度上
在語言科學上變成了更大的炎炎
但我希望從這裡取得的是
他分開了智慧
即是知識英文的語言
與表現
即是人們如何處理語言
與記憶結合之類的
我會說
基本上我們與表現的智慧
在語言模擬中有一個問題
像一個定義的轉換
像一個的數據精確
這是一個專業的分析
但是當我們看到
一個定義的轉換
我們會有一個表現問題
就是說
它們不會成功
我會在一分鐘內
展示這些
這是一種統治結果
好
所以
以回到運行理論上
我會說
我會有兩個
定義的轉換
我承諾了
所以我實際上是
U hat and A hat
U hat cannot sort
and A hat can
所以我用手製的重新定義
I compiled it to an A hat
但是我會用U-hat學習從數據
so what you can see
is you can see that
we're going to show
a few plots to wrap up
the trained U hat works pretty well
because it's doing
it's sorting pretty well on expectation
and the hand coded A hat does as well
但它們的長度也不一樣
but for different reasons
the A-hat fails to length generalize
是因為固定的準確準確的準確
防止它從執行它的algorithm
it wasn't in its expressive capacity
or expressive
或者表達性的
so see the A-hats
the aggregate accuracy
when I trained this thing
was 95%
but you can see with length
it tapers off
and these were run relatively hastily
so it might be exactly matching
但是這個是很適合這個數據的
我們可能會說
如果我們剛剛看了這個結果
這個東西學習解決
這裡是一個手寫的轉換器
它最後也會被解決
它的確率是97
所以比較相似
這個東西實際上會進行解決
然而
這個意義的認識
是非常相似的
所以這是一個
我認為是一個
專業的表現認識
是的
所以
重點就是
你可以適合這個數據
但仍然沒有學習這個數據
另一方面
另一端,你可以學習理論,卻仍然失敗在執行理論中
這是一個有趣的分辨,
就是當我們想到什麼種類型的解釋能力,
想要什麼樣的解釋,
我認為這種分辨是重要的
好,
結束一下,
我認為,
這是一個更有趣的哲學評論,
我認為這個古老的想法來自喬姆斯基的
整場收成兩句
第一
擬合的好不等於學會演算法
平均95分的模型
可能根本沒學會排序
從成績曲線上還看不出來
第二
Transformer能算的東西很少
卻把同樣的東西寫得非常短
短到找不到通用又有效率的方法
把它完整驗一遍
下一場是伯克萊的統計學家
賓 於
這場的主張是
一個有瑕疵的可解釋性方法
比黑箱還危險
因為它給你假的安全感
所以可解釋性方法要分級
像排行榜一樣
哪些方法有證據
哪些沒有
證據長這樣
從果蠅的基因裡
找出20組交互作用
文獻裡的實驗證實
其中八成是真的
原影片連結在說明欄
整場45分鐘
有興趣可以去聽更多